That sounded great that sounded great
Now of course we're going to go on to this other scene where actually
you're this is later now after you're trying to convince Maui on your mission [basically] and
And he's resistant to all this the interesting thing here is [that]?
You're trying to act like you know
Why the ocean chose you, but really  you don't that's something you've been trying to figure out
from the early part of the movie
It's just what was it about you that made the ocean choose you
you'd be a hero. that's what you're all about, Right
my people didn't send me the ocean did
the ocean makes sense you're what eight? can't sail obvious choice
It chose me for a reason
[and] you're gonna be meeting Maui
We've heard these stories about but of course your grandmother said you know he was a guy to watch out for and [TALKING ILLEGIBLY]
So you're kind of you're trying to gather yourself up? You're not sure what to expect
see the light as it shines on the sea, it's blinding
and no one knows, how deep it goes
I wish I could be the perfect daughter
But I come back to the water
no matter how hard  i try
so here i'll stay
my home my people beside me
and when i think of tomorrow there we   are
i'll lead the way
i'll have my people to guide me
we'll build our future together
where we are
okay, here we are
with moana meeting maui for the first time really on her own.
go ahead, take it away mr.
okay, so for a thousand years you've been alone on this island you lost  your fishhook you've had some rough times
and you find this boat and you don't know where it came from,  but you've been on this rocky island where a boat is a big deal
and you know you've had no force to you know, do do anything but now with this boat  you have a way to get off this thing
but hey, you know, we'd never make it past TeKah, not without my hook.
then we'll get it! get your hook, take out TeKah. restore the heart, unless  you don't want to be Maui,
demigod of the wind and sea, hero to all
all right, first we get my hook.
then save the world! Deal?
Deal.
Boat! a boat! the gods have  given me a  [PAUSES] Aah!
Maui, shapeshifter, demigod of the wind and sea, I  am moana of...
Hero of men
what?
it's actually Maui, shapeshifter, demigod of the wind and sea, hero of men. i interrupted, from the top, hero of men, go.
so, uh, daughter of the chief, right,  i thought you stayed in the village, you know kissing babies and things
hey, hey, hey,  i was just trying to understand why your people decided to send, oh how do i phrase this, what's that,  you.
okay, listen, let me tell you something, if the ocean is so smart, why didn't it just take the heart to Te Fiti itself, why didn't it just bring me my hook? huh!
i'll tell you why, the ocean is straight up kooky-dooks!
but, i'm sure it's not wrong about you, no,   you're the chosen one.
that's right, because it only appears after a human sacrifice. now come here,  kidding. why so serious.
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
Okay, don't worry, it's a lot farther down than it looks.
when you were waddling yay high, this guy! oh. when the nights got cold who stole you fire from down below, you're looking at him yo!
what is the takeaway, don't mess with maui when he's on a breakaway. and the tapestry here in my skin, is a map of the victories i win.
look where i've been i make everything happen, look at that mini maui just [talking illegibly.] hey!
well , anyway let me say you're welcome for the wonderful world you know. hey it's okay it's okay, you're welcome.
the tide the grass the ground, oh, that was maui just messing around. i killed an eel, buried it's guts, sprouted a tree now you got coconuts.
what is the lesson, what is the takeaway, don't mess with maui when he's on a breakaway.and the tapestry here in my skin.
ooh, ooh, hoo, oh. what is this thing it's like, it's kind of, it's got two legs, which is an unusual number
and what's, what' s this very stuff on top,  wait a minute, this is just a human, what's a human doing down here, in the realm of monsters.
wait, hey just pick an eye babe, it's distracting when you go back and forth like that, just pick one.  IN THE REALM OF MONSTERS
wait a minute are you just trying to make me talk about myself, because if so, you, you should have just said so.
i would gladly talk about myself. do you mind if i do it in song form
drab little crab once, now i can be happy as a clam, cause i'm beautiful baby.
did your granny say listen to your heart, be who you are on the inside
i need three words to tear her argument apart, your granny lied
i'd rather be shiny like a treasure from a sunken pirate wreck. scrub the deck.
and make it look, shiny!
fish are dumb dumb, dumb, , they chase everything that glitters, beginners
well well well, little maui's having trouble with his look, you little semi-demi-mini god.
ouch, what a terrible performance, get the hook,
you will die die die, now it's time for me to take apart
far from the ones who abandoned you chasing the love of the humans who make you feel wanted
shiny, soak it in cause it's all you'll ever see c'est la vie mon ami i'm so shiny
[LAUGHING] we talked a lot about crabs and mollusks.
i wanted to bring you here from the moment you opened your eyes.
this is a sacred place a place of chiefs there will  come a time when you stand on this peak and place a stone on this mountain,
like i did, like my father did, like his father and like every chief who has ever been.
and on that day, when you add your stone, you will raise this whole island higher.
you are the future of our people moana.   and they are not out there they're right here.
it's time to be who they need you to be
you are the future of our people moana, and they are not out there,  they're right here.
it's time to be who they need you to be.
and, mom, when grandmother says you gotta go on this mission. there's a scene, actually it's a pantomime,  but mom when moana is packing up, i gotta do this, i gotta go on this mission.
then she looks up and there's mom  in  the door and its like uh oh, what's she gonna do and mom kinda helps her pack up the stuff and gives her a hug.
so mom, even though she's been on dad's side all this time and she's kinda supported dad she's
she's been much more empathetic to moana's issues
the strength of her grandmother, the guidence, and then the spirit. even though her mother has to respect and understands
that you know we have to abide by these rules her spirit is like, -yeah, you should go- it' s like i believe in you
and you are chosen in some way and you can do this.
sometimes, who we wish we were, what we wish we could do.
it's just not meant to be. its just not meant to be
could have been worse, could have said it in front of your dad, standing on a boat [LAUGHS]
[MUSIC IN BACKGROUND]
We make our nets from the fibers, the water is sweet inside, we use the leaves to build fires and cook up the meat inside. x2
he was a demigod of the wind and sea a trickster, a shapeshifter, who wielded a magical fishhook,
and his name was maui
[LAUGHS] that's great ,so what if we go on.
you've been told all our people's stories but one.
what is this place
you really think our ancestors stayed within the reef
what's in there
oooooooooooh
[TALKS QUIETLY]
the answer
but one day, someone will journey beyond our reef find maui deliver him acros the great ocean to restore the heart of Te Fiti
i know a girl  from an island who stands apart from the crowd,  she loves the sea and her people, she makes her whole family proud
the people you love will change you, the things you have learned will guide you. and nothing on earth can silence, that quiet voice still inside you.
who you are
the people you love will change you, the things you have learned will guide you.
moana, you've come so far, moana, listen,  do you know who you are?
chief i'm telling you, every storm this roof leaks, no matter how many frawns we add
oh, chief im telling you oka fe fe every time this roof leaks no matter how many frawns
CHIEF! IT'S YOUR MOTHER!
alohahahahaha i'm filming, and the amazing Auli'i. aloha, and these are for you.
ah, thank you
i'm shooting everyone.  so everyone is in it.
uhh, come here
it's so good to see you, so good to meet you.
oh, it's so good to meet you too.
she is amazing in the movie wait till you see her, wait till you hear her.
i know what you're thinking, i go through this all the time, so for everybody, where's a
right there that s our number one camera. right here. those are great right.
they're beautiful, thank you.
right now she's like, wow, he's just so much, more handsome in person
one thing, so when you hear her in the  movie and it's just the first 10-15 minutes, you're like, ok this is gonna be good
and then she starts singing it's mic drop its game over
[TALKING ILLEGIBLY]
it' s nice to meet you
hello
how are you
i'm great how are you
meet your dad, meet your daughter
hi, spoiler, i don't listen to you much
hi grandma
hi baby girl! how are you
good
my gosh you look beautiful
thank you
can you believe that we design ed the character first.
i know look at you, you're totally moana
thank you
youre so gorgeous
[TALKING ILLEGIBLY]
i, you sound so different -yeah- but [TALKING ILLEGIBLY]
yes, yes you are.
thank you for being my grandma. oh pleasure thank you for being my beautiful mogel
see you soon ay. Good luck with everything, you are my...
where you are, where you are.
[TALKING QUIETLY]
you turned the wrong way
i can rotate her, her hand. closer back to her body so you don't see it as much
yeah, that's what i was wondering [TALKING ILLEGIBLY]
[TALKING ILLEGIBLY] the actual curves , that's what  this is
[TALKING ILLEGIBLY]
I love the way the manta rays are around gramma tala
this is gonna get huge laughs
[TALKING ILLEGIBLY]